the breaking news out of southern
california where there is a fast-moving
brush fire threatening more than 21
thousand people just
south of los angeles powerful winds
pushed the bonfire
to burn more than 1 500 acres in orange
county in just a matter of hours
jonathan vigliotti is tracking the
wildfire force
good morning to you and you can see how
the wind here is driving these flames
deeper into this canyon just take a look
at this plume of smoke
we're talking about wind gusts up to 70
to 80 miles per hour with embers flying
everywhere and sparking new fires where
we are in this canyon pretty remote but
on the other side of it several
neighborhoods
it's unclear at this point how many
people were forced to evacuate in the
middle of the night
the bonfire was sparked last night by a
house fire it's unclear
how that fire started because the power
here was turned off as a preventative
measure
to prevent flames like this from
starting another fire just south of here
in san diego started overnight it was
quickly put out
the focus though today operations here
on the bonfire
2 000 acres and burning zero percent
containment
this has been a historic wildfire season
here in the state of california more
than four million acres
and that number growing this morning the
red flag warnings
in effect through saturday with high
wind gusts expected
for several days gail boyce special
thanks to jonathan bigliotti who jumped
out of the car
shot that we're happy to tell you jump
back in the car and then left but when
we look at that you're thinking he's
breathing all of that i know very
dangerous
that's a very scary report thank you
very much